It's not simply a perspective enhancer,
it changes how you,
your body and your brain deal with,
with opiates.
I think a Tim Ferriss actually
talked about that before as well. Um,
but I mean, you know, I've seen it in my
practice and there are medical studies,
so I don't think that we should throw
out the fact that, um, you know,
cannabis can can help the opioid
crisis. And then also too, you know,
you want to look at it from a
clinical perspective, right?
So we know that opioids can kill people,
right? Cause it acts on the brainstem,
whereas whereas cannabis doesn't, so,
you know, you might be saying, you know,
you're just substituting
one for the other. And you
know, sometimes that is true,
but if you're using a less
harmful substance, you know,
to me that's like a huge win.
Right? So if someone you know,
has to drink 12 beers a night
versus smoking like one joint,
man, that's, that's awesome. I mean,
you look at all, all these clinics,
like you look at like Methadone clinics.
I mean, what are they doing there?
They're trying to get people
off one substance to, you know,
a substance that is a little bit less
harmful. And I think that when you,
when you use cannabis, you know, it
can be effective, uh, for, for opioids.
It can also be affected for,
for benzodiazepines and for
other medicines as well.
So, you know, I would be awesome
if everyone would just, you know,
feel happy and great all the time by just
exercise and nutrition and, you know,
that's what I advocate and that's
what I try to do personally.
And that's what I try to, you know,
say to my patients all the time.
But I understand though that,
you know, sometimes life is
hard. Sometimes, you know,
things hit you, you know, you
have, you have crisis in your
life, you have, you know,
personal crisis that can throw off
your mental health and then you have,
you get into a car accident, you know,
and you could be in really severe pain.
And in those times, you know,
sometimes diet, exercise,
meditation, doing all the right
things just isn't quite enough. And,
you know,
I think that it's great that we have
cannabis for those situations because it
does seem to be very effective and has
less side effects compared to some of the
other metals as compared to some
of the other medicines that we have
traditionally used. Um, and you
know, even though, you know,
I'm talking about opiates and deaths,
you know, we can also talk about insets,
right? Like nonsteroidal antiinflammatory
drugs. So, you know, the,
these drugs can also, you know,
wreck havoc under GI system. Um,
I saw one study, actually, I tweeted
out, uh, uh, Rhonda Patrick tweeted out,
said that if you use a and sets, it was
really short. I gotta look it up again,
but it was like two weeks. It can
decrease your, uh, your gonadotropins,
which can stimulate your,
your testosterone level by like 25%.
And on that note too,
we should talk about,
I can't believe I forgot to talk with
this, but opiates can drastically, um,
inhibit your, uh, your, uh,
testosterone production. Right?
Which is a huge thing for
depression because I've had
guys come in to me before,
um, that have been, uh, you
know, really, really depressed.
You just give them a small amount of
testosterone, a man, their author,
antidepressants, and they're off to the
races. They're doing great. So, you know,
are we creating a lot of people who are,
who are depressed because they're using
opiates and their testosterone levels
are low. And you know, for men, I mean
having low testosterone is horrible.
You know, your libido goes, you know what,
you're going to have low motivation. Um,
you know, you're not gonna feel as well.
You're not gonna want to do things. So,
you know, um, if you're giving someone
a medicine that, that, that nails there,
their testosterone levels down, that's
gonna really, you know, wreck wreck,
wreck havoc on their mental health.
And I just want to make a note to cause
Ben Greenfield who again, I really,
really respect. I like that
guy a lot. Um, you know,
it was talking a little bit with you
about testosterone and um, and uh,
and cannabis and how it can drop it.
So,
I think there was three studies
I saw done on humans. Um,
and two of them,
uh,
noted no statistical difference and drop
into testosterone levels and one study,
the other study noted a small
statistical difference. Um, so, you know,
I think that it may drop your
testosterone levels a little bit,
but it's not gonna you know,
substantially, um, drop
them. So just so people,
people know that because I know that
comes up all the time, you know?
Oh yes. As the, as the,
as the dumb anti drug advocates
like to say doobies cause boobies.
Oh yeah, that is, that
is, that is not right.
There was no [inaudible] no,
I'm joking. Um, risperdol
causes, that's a different issue.
Um, respire Dawson anti psychotic,
the spirit of, yeah, so, so look,
I think, I think the issue of
whether cannabis is a gateway drug,
it's 100% clear that
cannabis is a gateway drug.
The argument is when you say it's 100%
clear, the argument is why. Okay. So,
so it's quite clear that cannabis use
oftentimes proceeds other drug use,
whether it's opioids, cocaine,
other drugs. Now, one argument,
and this is actually a
pro legalization argument,
is one reason it's a gateway
is that if it's illegal,
you got to buy it from your
friendly neighborhood dealer.
He might have access to heroin or cocaine,
other drugs,
and so eventually maybe you decide
to try one of those other drugs.
So actually that's really
why the Dutch legalized.
They wanted to create an avenue for people
to use cannabis that wasn't connected
to other drugs.
Okay.
Another possibility is that using
an addictive intoxicating substance,
you might like it and you might
want to try other addictive,
intoxicating substances and
it might prime your brain.
And then the third possibility
really is that they're just,
some people are risk takers
out there, right? They use,
they're going to use cannabis, they're
going to gamble, they're going to end.
Cannabis is a little bit easier
to access than other drugs.
So they're probably going
to try cannabis first.
So it's not really that that
cannabis drives the use,
it's just the cannabis is first.
They're just curious people.
But your thoughts on what I would say,
I mean I'm just going to go back to
the NAM report. Right? And I mean,
I mean you quote these people
in your book, um, you know,
so this committee couldn't find sufficient
data demonstrating an association
between cannabis use initially opioid use.
They found no compelling evidence to
support the gateway drug theory. So,
so again, but that's most of the
people that you quoted in your book.
So there's been more research done since
then, but things have radically changed.
I would say things have
changed some, here's, here's,
here's what I would probably say.
I think that probably it's a combination
of these things, right? It's,
there's certainly an
environmental factor where again,
if you're buying from somebody who's
got an access to other illegal drugs,
maybe you try those drugs at
the same time getting high,
it feels good and maybe you want to try
other drugs and at the same time you're
just a risk taker. Okay. What is,
what nobody seriously ever said until
about the last five years is that cannabis
could be an off ramp for opioids.
Okay.
And there's a lot of reasons to believe
that's a really bad idea. First of all,
cannabis, if you actually
need opioids for pain relief,
cannabis is not a good enough
pain reliever. It's like alcohol.
It's a mild pain reliever. It's not
strong enough. You're dying from cancer.
Cannabis probably is not the pain reliever
that you need. You need opioids. Okay.
And again,
the state level data is not as good.
If you want to really figure out
what's happening to an individual,
the best way to do that is
to follow that individual.
And there's a really good paper that
came out in 2017 after the NAM reports,
so they didn't have it.
That shows that people who use cannabis
in 2001 is based on a large national
study in the U S we're three times as
likely to be using opioids three years
later. Okay. And that just
intuitively makes sense to me.
And the other thing that
people on the legalization,
I don't ever talk about is who are the
two countries that have the most cannabis
use in the west,
the US and Canada.
We're the two who are the two countries
that have by far the worst opiod
epidemic, the U S and Canada. Okay.
But there's a real issue with that
because the United States is also the only
country other than New Zealand that
allows pharmaceutical companies advertise.
I mean there's a,
there's Canada doesn't,
the amount of opiates that are
prescribed the United States is fucking
preposterous. I agree.
Particularly the, if the,
I don't know if you ever saw the
documentary, the Oxycontin Express,
but the way Florida used to be structured
where they didn't have a database,
you could just literally go
from pharmacy to pharmacy.
Yet we have a problem with the way
we prescribe drugs in this country.
Opioids add drugs, Benzos, ssrs,
all are connected to Canada.
So it makes sense that it
would filter over there. Yes.
But what I would say is the people who
think that cannabis is not part of that
overprescribing problem are
deluding themselves. And
what do you think did that,
so he, can you repeat the
question again? So, so, so I,
I agree with Joe the way that the
access to opioids in the US. I mean,
certainly it's come down a little bit in
the last couple of years, but you know,
Purdue Pharma, there's a special place
in hell for those guys. But not just,
it's not just opiates,
prescribe too many benzos.
We prescribe too many add drugs.
We probably prescribed too many SSR.
I's we prescribed too much in this
country. I think we all agree on that.
I agree with that.
I think that cannabis is another example
of us looking for a drug to solve our
problem. But what, what um, okay.
Again, just from a clinical perspective,
um, you know, I can't just rely on,
on Diet and exercise for all my patients.
I have to use other tools. And again,
like everyone here in this room,
like we're all pretty healthy.
I don't have a bad back or you know,
I don't have a mental health diagnosis
or anything going on. So, you know,
I have to look at patients
that are coming to me. Right.
So the way I see it is that, you know,
we just mentioned a bunch of other drugs,
you know, anti depressants and fetid
means all these types of things. You know,
cannabis, and again, you know, I'm going
to separate the chief. So you and the CBD,
it's an incredible medicine and
it doesn't kill people. Right?
So as a clinician,
you know that,
that's so comforting for me to know
that every single night I go to bed,
I killed zero people. I know
that. Right? So that's really,
really comforting for me to
know. Also, I feel, you know,
we just talking about amphetamines, we
were just talking about, you know, ssrs,
I feel that cannabis,
you know,
particularly the CBD component can
actually be more effective. You know,
that's what I've seen a lot in my practice
and other people have seen that as
well. So, you know,
I think that we need to need to take
that into consideration when we're using
all these drugs. And Alex, you know,
some of the things that you're saying,
you know, they're quite, you know, um,
admirable and in a lot of things
like researchers say, you know, are,
are quite admirable as well.
And, you know, they, they
feel that they can, you know,
tell clinicians, um, you know,
give them really good advice,
but they're not the ones in the trenches.
They're not the ones in front of the
people. They're not the ones that,
that have to have to chat with patients.
You know,
I have an obligation to do something
for my patients to make them better.
I really feel,
you know,
we just listed a bunch of drugs
that cannabis is a really,
really effective tool and, and it
doesn't kill anybody. So, you know,
because of that, you know, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna keep using it. But like I said,
I'm always looking for other drugs.
I'm always looking for other alternatives
that to also, um, help my patients.
But I think that,
you know,
using cannabis is a really effective
tool for a lot of clinicians and it's
helped a lot of patients.
But what do you think about his argument
about it being a gateway drug other
than what these people said in the study?
That there's no evidence that supports it,
it's a gateway drug.
What are your personal feelings about
that argument? So I don't feel that, uh,
that cannabis is a gateway drug. I do
feel that, you know, one of the, uh,
the things that you mentioned
earlier is that, you know,
some people kind of had this personality
where they're like an experiment, right?
And they, they just, they just want to
want to try something. So, you know,
the fact is,
is that alcohol and cannabis just get
introduced first most of the time,
most people, you know, don't do,
you know, coke or, or LSD and then,
hey, say, hey man, let us try some,
some cannabis. Right? So it's just that,
that's the very first one there. So
if we, so you could say anything that,
that, that was easier access. If there
were some new drug that you know,
did something similar to
alcohol or similar to cannabis
and that was introduced
in, in our society, you'd be
calling that the gateway drug.
Um, and I do feel, and I,
I do believe that nearly been demonstrated
as being the gateway drug to almost
all heart drugs because of
the loosening of inhibitions.
Whereas the opposite could be said about
cannabis that it makes you paranoid.
You might actually be less likely
to try cocaine afterwards. And,
and I know that the name,
uh, you know, they don't,
they don't feel that the cannabis is
a gateway drug either. I mean again,
they said,
you know,
they found no compelling evidence to
support the gateway theory. And again,
I mean these are the people that
you are quoted in your book out.
Let me just go a little bit further.
They said in a retrospective cohort study,
um,
may it from e t a l and the 2016 exam
and the transition from cannabis use to
the use of other elicit drugs.
They found that the probability
of initially other elicit
drugs after canvas did
not differ significantly
from the probability of,
of starting with other elicit drugs.
So it's just that cannabis is there first.
It's definitely not a gateway drug in
any stretch of the imagination. I just,
I totally disagree. And there again, 50
years of data on this. I know the
studies that he's quoting, but there are,
there are many others. And I think
the argument is as to why. And again,
I think the argument that that to some
extent having access to this drug via,
you know, illegally tends to open
you up to other illegal stuff,
which to me is an argument
for legalization. So, but I,
I do want to throw one thing out there.
You know,
I don't know how many of your viewers
have teenage kids or you know,
it's probably,
they're probably more likely to be
teenage kids and to have teenage kids.
But you know,
the book has,
the one thing that
really worries me in the,
if we're talking about gateway drugs
is that jewel and vaping are really a
gateway to THC. Vaping. So you can, you
know, you can refer to that because,
well first of all it gets people, it
gets kids, teenagers used to inhaling,
you know,
this elicit substance and you can
actually retrofit a jewel pod with THC.
They don't sell them,
but you can, you know,
you can easily go online
and look up how to do it.
And I think it really worries me,
and I've heard from a lot of parents in
the last month that there is an epidemic
of Nicotine,
vaping and TAC vaping going on
right now and that I think, and,
and we're talking about 15 1617
year olds inhaling pure THC,
the most dangerous form of this drug.
And I think unfortunately,
it's not going to take long before the
mental health consequences of that become
apparent.
And I really do hope that the book gives
parents some tools to talk to their
kids about that.
If nothing else.